so
yeah finally
finally finally won the game we are we
are with wesley was he only played two
games finally won a game
congratulations by the way first of all
on the win and second of all uh as my
board is moving by itself
uh
yesterday before we get into today
yesterday's game against shockwave you
must not have been happy about that one
as you were definitely rolling nah i was
gonna say yesterday
last night was very difficult to sleep i
probably spent
uh five hours sleeping and six hours
laying in the bed
wow very difficult to sleep because
yesterday was my chance like i had
probably ten different ways to win
and it's it's very tough to not win a
game like that like i think
if you were in my place you'd probably
win that game easily
but
yeah
but yeah i think yesterday
was not playing like himself like his
usual powerful self
so
uh i think he made many mistakes but
i should have con really converted that
game
but but it comforted me the fact that in
the grand chester there are lots of
blunders and
and it's incredible that the best
players in the world are sometimes
making elementary mistakes losing games
which they never should have lost or
drawing games which they would have 100
of the time
well today
your opponent made a big blunder first
of all on the clock his clock management
was incredible what were you feeling
when he sat and thought for 47 minutes
yeah at one point in the game yeah it
was very weird because yesterday shaq
was doing the same thing
like i was just
yesterday today i was just sitting on
the board uh watching my opponent's club
go lower and lower and nothing's
happening it's really weird because i
played this end game before and i think
sweers or darius
had it prepared until like move 22 or
something
and then we can go right here at this
monitor yeah i played this before online
this was the 47 minute thing right here
wesley after you played king
e7 this is where
uh direct just stopped yeah it's really
weird i mean i wasn't really expecting
anything more than a draw because end
game is very drawish but
i find it very weird why
he spent so much time in there only a
few pieces left on the board but
actually like in february 88 i played
king e7 before
against alexander grisschuck so i played
king e7 here i think h5 is the main line
so i thought i'd play a third move
like e7 the point is that after f4 black
can play some g6
and control the f5 square
but
i'm sure you've seen my game against
greece stroke so i thought i'd play rook
88
and confuse him a little bit take stakes
but
yeah i mean
or page four f6 game seven i i don't
think white has any winning chances but
at the same time he shouldn't lose
either
um
yeah like here i think he missed here
also that rook the f4 i have king g6
that's probably what he missed
so like if you play rook the f4
i can play king g6 and avoid the
perpetual check and white has some very
small problems
and
if he had gone rook f6 right away wesley
was this the rook at fix it was this i i
thought that this was the way to get the
perpetual chair i was gonna play with
hh2 right rook f4
there was a perpetual check in the
position why rock jeto dg2 check
rocky
and then
and check right what works i go up and
check go up
and check move up
and check
i can
h2 rook h2 and g5 g5 that was the draw i
thought he was
aiming for and now he's gone
ah yeah i missed the fact that white has
this
right
but he gave you
the chance that you were dreaming
yeah yeah yeah carrock f2
is uh
objectively a draw but practically with
two minutes left on the clock there
could be some tricks
and uh
before rook b2 checking g6 maybe rook e7
is also interesting but it's quite
tricky with very little time on the
clock right but i think it's like i i
set a nice strap here like c5 is a good
try i think
because if it takes on c5 then i get
rook a2 and 2 past pawns
right
so he played
he played rookie seven with two minutes
on the clock rook b6
rook c7 i thought a6 was very tricky
like it computer
gives a lot of ways to draw but it's
actually not that easy to find like
after rook c6 bc6
white only has one one way to draw
were you aware that it was a draw in the
game or did you think i'm winning this i
thought the spawn end game was winning
but i missed
because if you play a normal move like
king f4 you lose so you have to go to
the other side
because if you play king f4 then black
can play c5 and it's important to get
this pawn here
and i i was very proud of myself because
i calculated after king f4 c5 a4 a5
excuse me sorry okay
yes yeah a4 a5 yes i calculated the sun
king e4 kmg5 king d3 king g4 king c4
king f4
king c5 king e5
king b5 king d5
king a5 king c5
that's the nice move right thank you
king a6 e5 yeah a5 e4
king b7 e3
a6 e2
a7
name queen and queen ending yeah queen
if big the point is also after queen
queen e7
czech king
c8 queen eight or king a6 okay 2018 b7
queen d7 the point is why i cannot play
king a6 i was very proud of myself for
finding this and i thought i'm gonna win
but i i think white still has a way to
draw but fortunately he missed although
he didn't have to take on fife but it's
it's a bit difficult to
to defend with two minutes left this is
like your
run of the mill 20 move variation
yeah
yeah very nicely calculated wesley oh
thank you i was very happy when i saw
this because asics is quite tricky
but the crazy part is you did realize
though that it was a draw
or like if he goes if he jettisons the
g4 pawn right away
yeah no actually koscia showed it to us
from the
from a website when you came in okay and
you came in after the game so you
thought you were winning the whole time
but
did he say did he say anything about it
at all
yeah i think he also missed this idea of
king e3 right away and then king the
four kings
and we have another result as peters
fiddler has a drawn against shakira
mahmoud as we were expecting
wesley as we're going to get more
players coming down quickly let's ask
you this question
you need
have you calculated what you need to win
the grand chess tour yeah basically
i'm hoping fabiano would win the
tournament and then i would finish
second to last and then i would win the
grinch
i mean nicely calculated
i'm hoping fabi wins like seven in a row
then he'd finish clear first and uh
maybe
yeah okay somebody needs to talk to you
but that's the point if fabi gets 13
points and i get two then i still win
the grand junction
if shakriar and memphial yeah don't come
in second or third or maybe even fourth
so then fabi has to beat them so go
fabian
speaking
but but yeah my plan is just to play
some some good chefs uh avoid too many
blunders yesterday i made a couple all
right well congratulations on your win
today and uh
don't come in second time
nice danny wesley good luck we are being
told that we